We start with making a more
precise definition of an s-t cut.
Saying that it is
a partition of the vertices
such that the source s is in A and
the sync t is in B.
And B is defined to be the set
of vertices minus those in A.
For example, in this network here,
the green nodes might be A and
the orange ones B.
Or we might have this cut here.
The vertices within one side of the
partition don't have to be connected.
Next, we observe that f is an s-t flow,
and (A, B) is an s-t cut.
Then the value of the flow is equal to
the flow out of A minus the flow into A.
Which in turn is equal to the flow
into B minus the flow out of B.
In this example here, we have 1
plus 1 plus 5 plus 1 exiting A,
and 2 units entering over here,
for a total of 6.
And similarly for this cut here,
we have 2 exiting here and
2 exiting here, and 2 entering here,
again for a total of 6.
As you might imagine, the proof
comes from the conservation of flow.
We start with a definition of flow,
and then add 0 in the form of
the conservation equations for each
node in the A part of the partition.
For every edge where both vertices
are in A, the terms simply cancel,
because it'll pair once here,
and once here.
So we're left with the value
of the flow as being the sum
of the flows over edges.
Between A and B, minus the sum of
the flows over edges between B and A.
But this is just the flow out
of A minus the flow into A,
which of course,
is exactly what we wanted to prove.